you can say this is one cold-blooded
trailer hey cuz there's blood in it like
what Matt what's going on guys Greg Alva
here Shawn Humphrey here all right
hour-long podcast we're going to down
the snow man right now yeah just these
two minutes worth of footage oh yeah
there's plenty to break down especially
because we both read the books were the
right people to talk to about this
I've seen this movie the snowman coming
this Christmas 2017 yeah dude I feel it
it's very very cool like Christmas
horror military yeah yeah yeah I agree
with you there I read a book and I
really want to go Christmas well I can
see why October but you know I would
have been happy to have this at
Christmas
oh yeah you could have had it taking
place during Christmas in the snow and
one of those you know and I want that
pan that well for the girl the Dragon
Tattoo that we got a sequel for The Girl
with the Dragon Tattoo immediately think
totally right right right away they knew
to release psychological thriller on
Christmas yeah that's what people want
during the holidays when you're when
you're cuddling up with your family and
doing as cheerful things let's get back
on topic John yeah michael fassbender
chasing down a snowman guy
how long has gone inside out of the snow
man was actually a snowman I didn't
that's what it was it's a supernatural
thriller this'll bring a Michael Keaton
movie with mess up that prosecutor there
is actually a slasher movie called Jack
Frost and I think they made two of them
never didn't I've seen both you went
into on both of those movies and Michael
Fassbender in this role any time Michael
Fassbender is in a movie I had that
feeling of I want to watch it do I
always know but that's what I always
want to watch it because I feel pause
vendors and because I have work so I'll
check it out yeah this is the kind of
feel like I think I would watch you know
this isn't look you get a lot of horror
movie trailers nowadays and it's rare
when you see a movie that they advertise
terrifying novel I feel they don't get
them in each other's where they throw
that on as a title card so some be
terrifying novels do they adapt for them
to say that makes me
like I want to read the novel and I want
to check this out because I feel like
it'll be much more than just cheap jump
scare thrills it looks like a really
good detective mystery thriller where
the detective character is deteriorating
over time as a really good detective
thrillers go yeah yeah get involved in
this that sense of dread and foreboding
yeah like run down quality that's
supposed to take hold part way through
like you sort of feel movies like these
and they're done right Rebecca Ferguson
is in this trailer yeah and ever since
you know she's done movies before rogue
nation and she's done movies that are
coming out after rogue nation and I feel
like after rogue nation more people are
definitely more interested in who she is
as some actors and seeing a more of her
roles electoral on that movie I love
seeing Michael Fassbender Rebecca
Ferguson people who have played badasses
before they don't look like they're
playing badasses here but Rebecca
Ferguson still using her sex appeal to
lure in the kill that's always a
dangerous thing to do yeah that's
tempting fate right there but I feel
like she could attract more than just a
serial killer if she does those kind of
things feel like a lot of killers hate
attractive women doing attractive things
yeah and well because they blame them
for their lust the killers probably some
type of religious person like that's how
these killers go down they have like
religious qualities in them and lust is
wrong so when they start to lust they
blame the woman and I feel like that's
what he does with attractive woman is JK
Simmons JK Simmons the killer dude he's
British in this trailer where they shot
they way to cut the trailer together
made it look like JK Simmons was the bad
guy oh I wasn't even thinking about it
but I guess some why also they show JK
Simmons in this smaller supporting role
and not really promote him and all these
things and that's like maybe he's not
that big of a character no I don't think
so I wouldn't be surprised that JK
Simmons was the killer like oh he looks
like an important guy is that it a kind
of guy would be doing this yeah you know
they're probably going to investigate
they're going to question him not
because they're accusing him of being a
killer but they have some questions that
could lead to the killer they're gonna
find out it's him I'm not gonna take
your thing but I'll meet you halfway and
say I bet he's probably involved maybe
maybe maybe that's a good make home
maybe magneto
and could be sure to recorded
Ezio and and and J jonah Jameson in this
I don't know who played the Assassin's
Creed movie but Jay Jones yeah and this
trailer looks shot well it seems like
it's really taking advantage of its
atmosphere you know there is a certain
type of Hans snow can either be
beautiful or scared and you like they're
taking advantage of this kind of
atmosphere because when you kind of get
away in the snow it's hard you can drive
it's hard to run in it it's a scary
environment to be in if there's a killer
on the loose and plus it's always gory
when you like kill someone the Bloods
left on the snow we talked about this a
little bit in the in the just the actual
reaction part I'm really excited to get
another one of these kinds of movies you
know one of these sort of more it's got
horror in it but it's also a crime
thriller it's a little more I don't want
to say adult or mature it is more mature
it's like lots of the Lambs insomnia
zodiac those kind of horror thriller
yeah and I was thinking of the zodiac
and insomnia kind of all throughout this
trailer and I'm glad like especially for
Halloween time like it's cool as this
would be to have the actual winter for
Halloween time I like that this is an
option in my horror game take you know
something with a bit more of a caliber
cast and they are advertising as a
horror film but not looking like a
conventional horror film like this is
the kind of horror movie that audiences
that are more mature who usually looked
down on like what home is will tune in
for like you might not get they used to
turn it tuned in for it you might not
get 13 year old sneaking into the feeder
to go watch it I feel like you're
bridging the gap a little bit like with
that snowman head then yeah stuff like
that and I've heard a couple people
name-check like giallo like more Italian
style slasher movies that's a place
where you can get a lot of crossovers
when you have a police procedural and
then not a slasher but you know like a
serial killers big Galia slasher I hope
we get out to see that my truest hope
for this is that it's actually like like
a secret reboot kind of like Blair Witch
was where you know five days before the
movie comes out to reveal that this
really is the reboot of Jack Frost and
like we're finally going to get the
Snowman serial killer guy because that
you know as a horror fan I would be
confused well that's our trailer review
today people subscribe to the rail
rejects
click that notification belt please make
sure to check out our exclusive perks
and
rewards over at patreon.com slash the
real rejects which all helps to keeping
this channel running and John is John
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram good
day